Speaker 1: We now have reached a horrible
milestone in the United States where guns
are the leading cause of child deaths for those
under 18. The New York Times had a very good
piece on this a couple of days ago. And if you
look at leading causes of death for children
ages one through 18, if you're looking on the
screen, you see this green line, which is guns,
which has now surpassed motor vehicle crashes at
19% of deaths for children age 1 to 18. It is guns
followed by motor vehicle crashes, cancer drug
overdoses, which has increased and suffocation
has decreased, putting it into fifth position
into fifth position this century. Okay. Since
the year 2000, as you can see on the screen, if
you're looking, guns have risen as the cause of
death from 10% of kids age one to 18 to 19%.
Nearly five in 100,000 die each year. Kids.
These are stunning numbers. Most
of the deaths are homicides.
Many of the victims are black and mostly boys.
There are also suicides. The suicides are mostly
white and mostly boys. There are relatively few
of what would be called accidental deaths. We
take issue with the term accidental. Typically
you're talking about negligence, actually,
but very few are what are often called accidental
deaths. We hear about, oh, a dad was cleaning his
gun and shot his daughter dead. We do see those
stories, but those are actually relatively few.
This is a uniquely American problem. And
in order to start thinking about solutions,
we have to really understand the problem. This
is not a global epidemic. If you look globally,
the most common causes of death for children are
infectious diseases 45% disproportionately in the
developing world, 15% pneumonia and respiratory
disease, 12% preterm birth in neonatal disorders,
10% diarrheal categorized disease, 9%
congenital defects. Now, as a math issue,
it is true. I know people are going to write to
me and say this, so I will be very upfront with
you. If you reduce one thing simply by comparison,
another thing is going to go up. So in the U.S.,
we have certainly reduced some of these elements
as causes of death. Right. Diarrheal disease,
death in the United States, in kids is a lot rarer
than in other parts of the country. So if you drop
that, then other stuff will go up like gun deaths.
But even in the rest of the developed world where
there isn't much diarrheal child death, you do
not see gun death numbers like we see in the
United States. So what are the differences
between the U.S. and other countries? Well,
we have one of the highest rates of gun ownership.
Is it that alone? No, but that's a factor. One of
the highest rates of gun ownership. So there are
guns around kids. We have a lack of strict gun
control laws in most states. We have a culture
that glorifies violence and exposes even kids. I
mean, you know, we're talking 14, 15, 16, 17 year
olds completely exposed and affected by that very
culture that glorifies violence, sees guns as
a way to solve problems. High rate of poverty,
high rate of income inequality, both of which have
been studied in connection to guns as a public
health issue and lack of access to mental health
resources. Now, of course, I have no interest
in ignoring any of these aspects. The right
loves to say it's just mental health. Meanwhile,
they don't want to fund mental health.
Mental health is certainly a factor,
but availability of guns, widespread nature of
guns, that's a factor as well. There are clear
steps we can take. I've outlined so many of them
so many times before. No one step will solve this
problem. No one step will solve the problem. And
we always hear after a shooting, well, you know,
your idea of limit limiting clip capacity
wouldn't have prevented this particular shooting.
I don't know anyone who claims any one thing
when you have a problem that's based on 6 to
8 things. There's no one thing that will
solve that problem. But we have to work
on all of these things. And quite frankly,
the numbers speak for themselves unique to
the United States. If you want to let me put it
this way. If you want to find other countries
with a gun violence problem affecting kids to
the degree that we have in the United States,
I'm not going to name the countries. You will
find countries that none of these right wingers
would say are in any way equivalent to the
United States. So take a look. We're going
to link to the study in The New York Times.
We're going to continue talking about all of
it. But we have plenty of ideas. But we have a
right wing that is unwilling to actually try any
of them. Make sure you subscribe to our YouTube
channel YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.